for me it was not being invited to a
friend's wedding at first I didn't
really mind I thought he was having a
small reception but then I kept meeting
people who are going to the same wedding
and they weren't as close to the groom
as I was and I felt left out that really
sucked that felt really unfair for my
daughter's Lipsy and Greta it was last
week they were taking turns massaging
their moms back with the toy for back
rubs and then one of the girls felt the
other one had a longer go that's when I
walk into the room to find Greta in a
rage shouting that's not fair
and Lipsy in tears and my wife holding a
stopwatch to make sure that each girl
had precisely one minute on the toy so
if you're anything like me or my girls
the last thing that upset you probably
also had to do with unfairness
that's because unfairness triggers are
so strongly that we can't think straight
we become afraid and suspicious or
unfairness antennae stick up we feel
pain and we walk away unfairness is one
of the defining issues of our society
it's one of the root causes of
polarization and it's bad news for
business at work unfairness make people
defensive and disengaged a study shows
that 70% of workers in the u.s. are
disengaged and this is costing the
companies five hundred and fifty billion
dollars a year every year this is like
half the total spend on education in the
US this is the size of the GDP of a
country like Austria so removing
unfairness and promoting fairness should
be a priority but what does it mean in
practice is it about more rules is it
about systems is it about equality well
partly
but fairness is more interesting than
rules in equality fairness works in
surprising ways fifteen years ago I left
a US investment bank to join a large
Italian state-owned oil company it was a
different world I thought the key to
getting the best performance was a risk
reward system where you could give the
high performers bonuses and promotions
and give the under performers something
to worry about but in this company we
had fixed salaries and lifelong jobs
careers were set
so my toolkit wasn't very effective and
I was frustrated but then I saw that
this company was producing some pockets
of excellence eras in which they beat
the competition in very tough
competitive sectors this was true in
trading in project management was very
true in expiration our exploration team
was finding more oil and gas than any
other company in the world it was a
phenomenon everyone was trying to figure
out how this was possible I thought it
was luck but after each new discovery
that became less and less likely so did
we have a special tool no did we have a
killer application that no one else had
know was it one genius who was finding
oil for the whole team no we hadn't
hired a senior guy in years
so what was her secret sauce I started
looking at them really carefully I
looked at my friend who drilled seven
dry wells writing off more than a
billion dollars for the company and
found oil on the 8th I was nervous for
him but he was so relaxed I mean these
guys knew what they were doing and then
it hit me it was about fairness these
guys were working in a company where
they didn't need to worry about
short-term results they weren't going to
be penalized for bad luck or for an
honest mistake they knew they were
valued for what they were trying to do
not the
outcome they were valued as human beings
they were part of a community whatever
happened the company would stand by them
and for me this is a definition of
fairness it's when you can lower those
unfairness antennae put them at rest
then great things follow these guys
could be true to their purpose which was
finding oil and gas they didn't have to
worry about company politics or greed or
fear they could be good risk takers
because they weren't too defensive and
they weren't gambling to take huge
rewards and they were excellent team
workers they could trust their
colleagues they didn't need to look
behind their backs and they were
basically having fun they were having so
much fun one guy even confessed that he
was having more fun at the company
Christmas dinner than at his own
Christmas dinner but these guys
essentially were working as fair system
where they could do what they felt was
right instead of what selfish was quick
what's convenient and to be able to do
what we feel is right is a key
ingredient for fairness but it's also a
great motivator and it wasn't just the
explorers who are doing the right thing
there was an HR director who proposed
that I hire someone internally and give
him a managerial job this guy was very
good but he didn't finish high school so
formally he had no qualifications but he
was so good it made sense and so we gave
him the job or the other guy who asked
me for a budget to build a cheese
factory next to our plant in Ecuador in
the village it didn't make any sense no
one ever built a cheese factory but this
is what the village wanted because the
milk they had would spoil before they
could sell it so that's what they needed
and so we built it so in these examples
and many others I learned that to be
fair my colleagues and I we needed to
take a risk and stick her head out but
in a fair system you can do that you can
dare to be fair so I realized that these
guys and other colleagues were achieving
great results doing great things in a
way that no bonus could buy so I was
fascinated I wanted to learn how this
thing really worked and I wanted to
learn it also for myself to become a
better leader so I started talking to
colleagues to coaches to headhunters and
neuro scientists and what I discovered
is that what these guys were up to and
what the way they worked is really
supported by recent brain science and
I've also discovered that this can work
at all levels in any type of company you
don't need the fixed salaries or the
stable careers this is because science
shows that humans have an innate sense
of fairness we know what is right and
what is wrong before we can talk or
think about it my favorite experiments
has six-month-old babies watching a ball
trying to struggle up a hill and there's
a helpful friendly square that pushes
the ball up the hill and then a mean
triangle pushes the ball back down after
watching this several times they ask the
babies to pick to choose what to play
with they can click a ball a square or a
triangle they never pick up the triangle
all the babies want to be the square and
science also shows that when we see or
perceive fairness our brain releases a
substance that gives us pleasure proper
joy but when we perceive unfairness we
feel pain even greater pain and the same
type of pain as if I really hurt myself
that's because unfairness triggers the
primitive reptile part of our brain the
part that deals with threats and
survival and when unfairness triggers a
threat that's all we can think about
motivation creativity teamwork they all
go way back and it makes sense that were
wired this way because we're social
animals we need to be part of a
community to survive we're born so
helpless that someone needs to look
after
until were maybe 10 years old so our
brain evolves towards a food we need to
be in that community so whether I like
it or not not being invited to the
friend's wedding generates my lizard
brain is generating the same response as
if I'm about to be pushed out from my
community so science explains quite
nicely
why fairness is good and why unfairness
makes us really defensive
but science also shows that in a fair
environment not only we all want to be
the square but we tend to be the square
and this allows other people to be fair
in turn this creates a beautiful
fairness circle but while we start off
fair one drop of unfairness contaminates
the whole pool and unfortunately there's
plenty of drops in that pool so our
effort should be to filter out as much
unfairness as we can from everywhere
starting from our communities starting
from our companies I worry about this a
lot because I lead a team of 3,000
excellent people and the difference
between 3,000 happy motivated team
workers and 3,000 clock Watchers is
everything so the first thing I try to
do in my fairness crusade is to try to
take myself out of the equation that
means being aware of my own biases for
example I really like people who say yes
to whatever I suggest but that's not
very good for the company and not very
good for anyone who has different ideas
so we try to actively promote a culture
of diversity of opinions and diversity
of character the second thing we do is a
little more procedural we look at all
the rules the processes the systems in
the company the ones we use to take
decisions and allocate resources and we
try to get rid of anything that's not
very clear not very rational doesn't
make sense and we also try to fix
anything that's limiting the transfer of
information within the company
we then look at the culture and the
motivation for the same reasons but my
point is that however hard you look at
the rules the processes the systems and
we have to
do that but however hard we look we're
never gonna do enough to get to the real
essence of fairness that's because the
last mile of fairness requires something
else it's about what people's emotions
are what their needs are what's going on
in their private lives what society
needs these are all questions and
elements that are very hard to put into
a spreadsheet into an algorithm it's
very hard to make them part of our
irrational decision but if we miss these
we're missing key important points and
the outcome is likely to feel unfair so
we should cross-check our decisions with
our fairness Center switched-on is it
right that this guy should get the job
he's really hoping to get is it right
that this guy should be fired is it
right that we should be charging so much
for this product these are tough
questions but if we take the time to ask
ourselves whether the rational answer is
the right one we all know deep inside
what the answer is we've known since we
were babies and to know what the right
answer is it's pretty cool for decision
making and if we turn on our hearts
that's the key to getting the real best
out of people because they can smell it
if you care and only when you really
care they will leave their fears behind
and bring their true selves to work
so if fairness is a keystone of life why
isn't every leader making it their
priority wouldn't it be cool to work in
a company that was more fair wouldn't it
be great to have colleagues and bosses
that were selected and trained for
fairness and for character and not based
on 60 year old ji Matz wouldn't it be
nice to be able to knock on the door of
a chief fairness officer we'll get there
but why isn't it not happening now well
partly it's because of inertia partly
it's because fairness isn't always easy
it requires judgment and risk
drilling that eighth well was a risk
promoting the guy who didn't finish high
school was a risk building a cheese
factory in Ecuador was a risk but
fairness is a risk worth taking so we
should be asking ourselves where can we
take this risk where can we push
ourselves a little bit further to go
beyond what's rational and do what's
right thank you
[Applause]